the go Street Ghost Recon wildlands Oh
closed beta was last week or open closed
for honor open beta what the [ __ ] is
going on yes was we were playing on ps4
and PC last week in the office and over
the weekend I think it was like Friday
to Sunday we did a stream of it too and
if you don't know much about wildlands
yet it's essentially they're making this
open-world sandbox in Columbia and
you're essentially trying to take down
the drug cartel because there aren't 300
movies and games we're doing that
already it's fresh rotten ground never
never been there but after the take away
that like Jake Dekker was playing and he
was the one that kind of raised the idea
for this segment Aaron Sampson was
playing I know Rob tried it out I
couldn't get past the menu Rob Handler
and Jake while they were yeah I was
connected but then there was this
overlay saying you can't connect to the
servers but then in the background on
the main Telstra he said you're
connected but then that would go away
now try to play a game and said you're
disconnected I don't know what it was I
been having problems that you like with
foreign or Ubisoft connection play
something with yeah yeah or something
like our NAT type which no idea what CBS
is up to but hopefully they're not
watching I don't want to be fired
they're making that show about the Nerds
the show about the nerves the show about
the nerdy thing
nice I actually didn't know what you're
talking about I don't know you were
kidding right what you didn't forget to
know anyway after playing that people
said you know it's kind of a common
phrase with as a new sequels come out
and these franchises start evolving and
adapting and kind of trying to figure
out what audiences want and what they're
gonna pay for more specifically it feels
more like people are saying this seems
like they're going for a GTA thing with
ghosts recons I made the comparison
watching Jake play you know like scoping
out an area kind of sneaking in I made
the comparison to Metal Gear Solid 5
from the game which you and I both
really liked Kelly you were saying yet
and played too much of it yeah no okay
it's essentially just the the whole loop
of the stealth in an open-world right
you don't have to be stealthy miss the
big thing they push I think it was an e3
reveal like two years ago
2015 I believe Ubisoft is saying yeah
you can they showed the same gameplay
trailer twice just one that going in
guns blazing one being stealthy this
looks almost exactly like the first
mission to know yourself of the first
mission totally yeah and it essentially
people are saying it doesn't feel like a
Ghost Recon game which I don't aim right
I don't always like like resin evil 7
doesn't feel like resin evil game but I
think they had it done well sorry at
first glance it is not but then you
start playing and you see the roots of
it but people are saying they don't see
any time cleansing this a lot like aside
from the aesthetic the military
aesthetic right it's not Tom Clancy I
thought you play this time cleans that's
ding chavez that main character from the
rogue Rainbow six it's not thing Sean
sighs Dean that's willem dafoe
wei-ting have you seen the movies read
the books I used to be a huge time
Clancy nerd that's why I wanted to do
this segment um and you were limiting
that microphone in anticipation of
something I don't know what I what no
one can we talk about the name ding
really quickly it's Dana's I'm not
kidding have you guys seen on clear and
present danger patriot games all the
time Quincy stuff here's some Ford stuff
yes and then he the one of the main
recruits from Rainbow six is ding chavez
look it up you can play it I told you we
have to get like Rainbow six rogue spear
footage ready we're gonna get into the
argument this segment soon but I want to
like show you what I like about this
what I like about like Tom Clancy stuff
it's ok rogue Spears one of my favorite
games and I think that when you lose
that you can play this in third-person -
which is what I always did it looks
cooler
I wish that was ding chavez at the
bottom that's not that is a nor of a
cough I don't know this is not a cough
Vladimir Nabokov the author is using
Spetsnaz now
no it's essentially wildlands like jake
decker were just chatting in the twitch
chat it feels like they're going for
more of a open world sandbox thing
whereas like you know the division was
going for more of the RPG lucre and
destiny kind of game and in some ways
and then you have rainbow succeed who
started off as this tactical team
shooter but now as they introduced the
updates Aaron Sampson plays a lot he's
been saying it's becoming less and less
tactical and it's falling more into that
hero shooter category almost which you
know like like overwatch battleborn
class based shooter class based shooter
every time I hear the word battleborn I
guess I'll throw that all born into the
conversation anytime I think that games
fun but I want to talk to you guys about
whether you think Tom Clancy give in to
losing their identity because I like I
said I I'm not always one of those
people who says like oh this doesn't
feel like a Zelda game or this doesn't
feel like a Metroid game but in this
case I don't want Tom Clancy to just
become just this homogeneous thing that
blends in with all the other franchises
because Tom Clancy games to me were
always that there were the tactical
things to it when they first showed off
the trailer for Rainbow six Patriots
when you had to make those decisions
like do I throw this civilian off the
bridge to but the bomb blow him up but
also not hurt like 500 more people like
that was cool because that was the you
know like the fighting in the shadows
when no one really knows you're there
kind of there's no glory it's just these
pre-emptive military strikes Rainbow Six
Vegas I love those two games they're the
tactical first-person shooters but so
what does this retain that does resemble
Tom Clancy that's what that's what
everybody saying with wildlands it seems
like there's even less Tom Clancy than
the division had which the division
didn't have much to begin with just the
aesthetic so it's like Tom Clancy's just
this like yeah it's it's like a paint
now yeah well okay I mean I can
understand I think that sometimes a
franchise deviating from its roots is
can be a good thing I I also think like
when you are a fan of something that's
known for like Tom Clancy being known
for tactical elements having it shift so
far away from that when there are other
options for similar games that are doing
the same things it's trying to do it's
like okay well why did I bother buying
this game if I can play you know black
ops 3 and pick like a specialist and
it's basically like you have a sort of
hero thing going on like why do I need
another game like this I went to Tom
Clancy for tactical stuff and now I
don't have that so I can understand the
frustration yeah totally it's it's the
wanting to make money in the short term
based on these trends right and then but
in the long term what are you
sacrificing maybe it's what Thomas wants
can I call him Thomas
sure I
Thoms I think it usually you start with
formal you start with the formal thing
and then when you get familiar you
compound yeah klancy son comb okay my
boy tease games right now have been kind
of like losing what I love about them
and yeah short term they're kind of
maybe cashing in is really just being
reductive and being kind of mean to
Ubisoft but I feel like they're cashing
in on the destiny Luke grind MMORPG
cooperative shooter experience like I
said realistic seeds I think he's
catering more to that class based
shooter structure I think I'm scared and
then Eric Greenwood that brings up a
very good point in YouTube Mike should
ask himself if the marketing of applying
the Tom Clancy name works in making him
buy a game he may not otherwise have
bought very very good point because if
the division was not a Tom Clancy game I
still would have tried it and I think I
would have had less expect expectations
whereas I don't think I would care about
wild lands if it wasn't a Tom Clancy
game so butter - there's a two-sided
coin right there maybe more of the
themes in the setting that kind of makes
you feel like there's a stronger
connection this time around is something
Tom Clancy would be a part of but then
the mechanics fall short with wild ants
yeah probably yeah because that's the
original like Tom Clancy stuff was about
drug cartel in South America and that's
why I was attached to it but like Eric
green mentioned I don't think I would
care about wild lands because it looks
like it looks like they're going for a
dumbed down vanilla kind of male Gear
Solid 5 experience we don't know if it's
done we we stay on but well from what we
everybody's playing it from what I
played it didn't feel that was a beta
that's true yeah obviously this is all
based on my beta experience but I didn't
get like the last Ghost Recon was Future
Soldier and I actually really liked that
it wasn't the best one but I think the
campaign was really good I think it
emphasized this kind of modern combat
this like pre-emptive military strikes
with drones with these like with robots
and whatnot but also it kind of had some
cool things to say about that as it went
through about like the dehumanization of
war and whatnot sure
but I still liked it because it felt
like a Tom Clancy game and like I said
this is weird for me because I usually
am NOT one of those people who says like
oh this doesn't feel like a Zelda game
why are they doing this like their
sacrifice what made it great to begin
with in this case I feel like they're
taking they're picking apart one
specific franchise a newbie
sparked and just kind of exploding it
out to meet all these different trends
and that's why I'm kind of worried
because I actually played more the
division recently it's been like six
episodes the lobby or I've said I've
wanted to get back into playing and I
did and I liked the survival mode I
think that actually fits into the
division well for those who don't know
that's where you're actually going
through this post or like disease
infected posts almost post-apocalyptic
Manhattan and try and survive through
the cold and through your thirst and
hunger but wild lands from what I've
seen and from what I've heard and from
the brief time I've played in the beta
again it did not feel like I was playing
this tactical game at all and that's
what I was looking for with it like a
tactical shooter in a sandbox I mean
you're not gonna be I don't think a
game's gonna come along anytime soon
that's better than meld your solid 5 at
doing that yeah and I don't dislike the
fact that they're going for that but it
doesn't feel it feels like it's missing
the mark now the coop the coop side of
it makes it a little more enticing I
know Jake that grant Aaron Sampson and
Rob handler having much more fun playing
in co-op so I'll probably play this when
it comes out but like Eric green had
mentioned would I be as interested if it
wasn't a Tom Clancy game no and I but I
would have been more insted in the
division I think if it was just its own
thing and I wasn't expecting at the
atomic Lancie game sorry correction I
would have enjoyed it more if I wasn't
trying if I didn't think it was a Tom
Clancy game so I was just worried that
in the long term what does it even mean
to be a Tom Clancy game anymore like
five years down the road if all of these
different properties Ghost Recon I think
Roger and new I think it's already been
diluted and I wish like Rainbow six
stuck to its roots people in the chat
are saying it's still pretty tactical
and I agree but I think and Aaron
Sampson is as dissected the game a lot
he's a video producer here he was saying
that just like a lot of the updates are
doing or making it more of just a
regular shooter still tactical much more
tactical than you know like overwatch or
something of that ilk but now it's just
I feel like it's kind of being this
vanilla tactical shooter rather than
this really hardcore hate using that
phrase because it sounds like I'm
alienating and marginalizing people that
just want these shooters but I feel like
Tom Clancy and
like you said maybe we're already there
and Tom Clancy games don't mean what
they used to be I'm sad now but but then
there's these rays of hope like
resonable 7 I know I just earlier use
that example that was me thinking out
loud because res evil six was the one
we're like what the [ __ ] is this res
evil 7 is a return to the roots which we
keep saying you would it make sense
yeah I all modern palates and that's
resonable 7 we I have something else
going up soonish about why I think res
equal 7 is actually really [ __ ]
important game because one of Japan's
biggest developers and one of the like
leading franchises at least well maybe
not in recent years but Resident Evil
itself the fact that they could kind of
take a risk and go back to survival
horror is kind of proof that maybe
people should do this so maybe you know
like obviously this is a stretch but
maybe Ubisoft needs to look at resonable
7 and say how can we take what made Tom
Clancy game's great to begin with and
adapt it in our own way rather than
follow destiny or follow or how can I do
some fancy name and break out the things
that people like and make them their own
franchise exactly making another new IP
like the division but in its own kind of
game destiny clone survival mode if
you're gonna play division play survival
mode yeah the next splinter cell game
would be yeah if so blacklist speaking
of speaking of that Splinter Cell
blacklist Thank You Billy comb for
bringing up Splinter Cell I'm sure other
people did I just didn't see the chat
spawn herself back blacklist I really
actually thought did this well but that
was what mm [ __ ] 12 blacklist you guys
remember some of the chapters tell me
what your Splinter Cell blacklist was
I'm forgetting right now it was like at
least four years ago I think they did a
great job because you have those three
trees you can go down where you actually
you can play the traditional Splinter
Cell it was a very good stealthy if you
wanted to but then they have these side
quests when you're going and this
mission is very much stealth don't even
get seen if you're if these missions you
will immediately fail if you're seen
yeah kind of like a Dishonored
like completely non-lethal run or
anything and then there's this one tree
where it's assault and it felt good for
a third-person shooter it didn't feel
like Splinter Cell but it was still an
option and then like the last boss fight
and that game is [ __ ] I love
everything about this game except for
that last
by blacklist I think is a example of
what Tom Clancy games need to be it took
what made Splinter Cell great to begin
with and it didn't sacrifice that but
also add it on to it I think it that did
it from modern palates and I really
liked it I don't know did you play
blacklist no but I mean just from you
describing it I think that's a really
smart way to adapt something for both
like returning and like returning
players and introducing it to new people
is like giving options I think that's
smart
it's hard to execute sometimes but sure
and then they have like you kind of just
saw like you mentioned black ops 2 & 3
or sorry black ops yeah black ops 3 with
the specialists yeah
black ops also has that hub like
campaign no black ops has that hub in
the campaign that's what Call of Duty
games started doing because infinite
warfare head as well where you that's
where all the RPG mechanics are tied
into you like afraid your weapons lack
of us did that really well and I think
that was a very modern trope at the time
and it still is I guess but you go back
between missions to pick you know that
old-school map which neo actually has
like Mario map you're picking yourself
picking like which parts of the Mushroom
Kingdom you want to infiltrate I haven't
played it I recommend it okay I think
we've talked enough about how worried I
about your system I think so
did you get that YouTube get out of your
system yeah last week cally what do you
want to vent about I was secretly still
hate it I come back to me on that I'm
angry about so much so much anger
alright for those just joining we are
good get into neo and intend to switch
so we will get to those we have one more
segment we have a bit of an odd segment
for lobby stuff but I'm excited to show
it um first off if you have any thoughts
I see mr. Rajah nadir so you just still
extremely tax come all the more
operators they had the more tactical if
he comes I totally agree I think they're
still going for the hero class based
shooter but I appreciate the fact that
it's still much more tactical than like
overwatch or battleborn or what other
class based shooters came out last year
keep trying so hard not to say here I
love it yeah but also when I titanfall 2
had like class-based shooter things like
with the Titans they went
no hero shooter because I used to be a
class-based shooter and then they made
it into a hero shooter with these
superhuman these super-powered Titans
one has like flame powers there's a
perks like micro kind of works when I
describe let me describe this like
someone an entity that shoots flames
sure mainly has powers around flames or
powers around lasers or powers around
missiles what would you call those like
someone with superpowers that you know
does good deeds what would you call that
Peter Brown now see I would look and try
to figure out the roles that they fill
in general sense then apply that to a
class wouldn't get hung up on
superficial details like fire okay
people in chat let me know your thoughts
about Tom Clancy I'll try to keep up but
also tweet at me Mike my Hardy Peter
Brown Kelly plaguey for your thoughts
[Music]